titles are one of the most
important aspects of winning on youtube
if you want to get views if you want
people to click through
on your videos you have to level up your
titles
and so in this video i'm going to be
sharing some title formulas that are
proven to get clicks and massive views
and the first one is the versus title
we're also going to be covering some
practical tips
that you can implement immediately to
help you make your next video better
and actually how to come up with good
video ideas and i've got three specific
title formulas but
the first one is the versus video and
let me know have you ever made a versus
video
before a couple videos that have crushed
on think media
the canon g7x mark iii versus the mark
ii almost a quarter million views
this is very powerful for products when
a new version comes out
i was just researching the jbl boombox
one versus two
is the two worth the money and so very
powerful for product reviews
a lot of ways you can monetize those the
rode
videomic ntg versus the deity pro
um canon versus sony that's a more macro
conversation
canon versus sony um camcorder
versus dslr for video
so that's not a specific product that's
a category comparison
one of our students in video ranking
academy has a golf channel and she's
been
getting some great videos that have been
breaking out scramble
versus best ball golf rules 3
500 views by using the versus title and
the versus strategy
what is a nas or nos drive how do you
actually say it
external hard drive versus nas explained
now this is two strategies we teach asq
answer specific questions people are
wondering what is this
particular type of drive they're also
wondering uh and then it's also the
versus title formula right so
it's it's kind of stacking strategy
stacking
in the title and look at how well this
video is done
it continues to get views this is the
power of putting out a good video with a
great title that essentially ranks in
search
and suggested this video has
353 000 views it's grown the channel by
4 000 subscribers it's made almost
1500 so far just from ads a ton more
from affiliates
and it gets 1 64 views every two days
that's 26 views an hour and then the
biggest traffic source on it at the time
of taking this screenshot
is actually suggested videos and browse
features and youtube search is only 20
so that is the power of a really really
strong title
so let me know if you've ever done a
versus video before or if you have an
idea of a versus video that you could do
and here's a couple examples blendtec
versus vita
vitamix for smoothie whey protein versus
plant protein
socialism versus capitalism explained
homeschool versus public school heather
taurus on the think media team did that
best camera for youtube m50 versus sony
a6400
cbd versus tylenol treating
pain and inflammation see some of those
ideas
what's a versus video you could do and
these three strategies or rather title
formulas in this video
come out of our guide the 15 best
youtube title formulas
guide that we have and so i'm going to
be going through three of them
today but hey if you're new to the
channel my name is sean cannell
and this is coffee with kannel we're
going to be talking about how to title
your youtube videos to get more views
and i'm gonna be sharing three title
formulas with you
so hit like if you're fired up and if
you've already gotten value so far
and as typical on the show later on
i take your questions after we get
through the main content so we have two
more title formulas to get into
so let's do it today's episode is
brought to you by the youtube starter
kit
if you would like to get all 15 titles
in the title guide
our thumbnail training 51 money making
ideas
all kinds of really cool stuff
tubestarterkit.com it's a
digital asset bundle power pack there's
templates there's tutorials
you're gonna love it and we are doing
over 90 off holiday special on it
and so if you haven't checked it out yet
link in the description down below
tubestarterkit.com and
you actually get a ticket included now a
free ticket to our youtube
strategy workshop for the new year and
so
this is a 97 event it's four hours
heather's training i'm training tony
ariela's gonna be there there's
workshops there's a downloadable pdf
we're giving away a sony zv1 some other
tech gear
it's gonna be an incredible event here's
the title it is
youtube strategy workshop learn the new
rules of youtube success and create your
stress-free
youtube growth plan for winning in 2021.
if you'd like to jumpstart your channel
and plan a whole year's worth of content
in one hour
you're not going to want to miss this
and um it's a 97
ticket but it's a free bonus
included in our holiday bundle for the
starter kit
and so if you want all the details
that's at tubestarterkit.com
get 90 off get a free ticket to the new
year's
strategy workshop it's going to be
amazing let's get into title number two
from our title formula guide how-to
titles
now these might be something that's kind
of known but let's talk about it did you
know that 65
of people use youtube to help them solve
a problem
and that youtube searches on how to have
grown 70
year-over-year people continually go to
youtube looking for answers to specific
questions
and how-to titles can be very popular in
the thumbnail
i said viral titles it's pretty viral to
me i did a how-to video how to get free
stuff from
amazon got 2.9 million views
it's a pretty good how-to title in fact
if you look at these top videos on think
media
1.4 million views 1.4 1.9 2 million
views
how to come up with a youtube name how
to make 1 000 on youtube
how to make youtube videos on your phone
how to make youtube videos start to to
finish
how to what's a how-to video you could
make have you made a how-to video before
in your title here's nicole uh one of
our video reiki academy students how to
become
an ot specialist occupational therapy
okay she's a kid's occupational
therapist how to burp a newborn
i got a 10 week old now 11 weeks so i'm
trying to figure that out right so how
to
burp a newborn 53 000 views friends 64
000 views
but the kind of content that continues
to get views
week after week month after month and
even year
over year to grow your channel and get
you views the how-to title
um this is mary's nest how to make cream
cheese
735 000 views like what are we talking
about
so she's done how to make apple cider
vinegar
how to make rich bean beef bone broth
how to make homemade sauerkraut crushing
it
not the only title none of these no
channel that i'm referencing here and
these are
a lot of people that are you know part
of our community and some of our
advanced training
but it's not the only title they're
using this is why you want
a tool belt of powerful titles
video ideas and really lenses to think
about your next video through
and if you study the videos you've been
uploading
and you're not using some of the most
powerful title strategies
well then you're missing out on video
formats that could really help you grow
your channel
techno dad how to choose the right
speaker wire
home theater basics you'll see some
power in the way that
they're stacking their titles there's
kind of like there's the question there
there's some other things cowboy kent
rollins how to use
cast iron cooking cleaning and seasoning
really strong title
712 thousand views gotta love it fly
ride
custom led lamps for cars right
how to customize your headlights how to
build custom sequential led strips
how to install demon eyes and honeycomb
lenses
so how to i mean 336
359 636 000. this is crazy y'all
so the right how-to video about the
right topic what the right
content can be really powerful here's
some ideas how to lose weight fast
without exercise at home
especially during the pandemic and
lockdowns pretty strong you may even
niche down more than that but that's a
good starting point
how to save money with low income how to
study the bible for beginners
how to cook steak in a cast iron skillet
how to make the best apple pie
without an oven how to make a youtube
video
okay so that's the how to title formula
and you'll see that it's not enough to
obviously just put how to in there you
want to power the whole thing up
like how do i lose weight fast
without exercise at home
it's like a triple stack man i don't
know if you like jack-in-the-box but you
got like three big beef patties on there
like you're ready to get to work
vegans are offended let's keep going so
um how-to titles
number three mistakes have you ever made
a video with mistakes in the title and
what's your most viewed video and what
was the title i'm curious
on your channel what's your most viewed
video and paste the title on the
comments
so that um i could see like maybe you
maybe one of these are them maybe
there's something powerful you could
learn from your most powerful title
topic if you will grayscale gorilla are
you making these five
animation mistakes in cinema 4d 30
000 views the type of video that really
has value it's like a fine wine it gets
better with age
you know what i mean this is three years
old but people keep watching it
when they want to learn about cinema 4d
maybe animation mistakes that they're
making
darren kidd how to grow your network
marketing business
three biggest mistakes that's a stack
you see that little
stacker variation right how to
and mistakes are in that first one why
people fail in network marketing five
reasons explained
i included that one because it's a
variation it's a variation on
the negative because there's the
positive like how to
grow your network marketing business
then there's like why it's not
growing and the mistakes you might be
making so if you vary
you know do a variation on the title why
people fail in network marketing like
why do they fail
here's the five reasons basically it's
the five mistakes they're making makes
sense
so sometimes you don't have to look at
these as so black and white you can sort
of
use them as inspiration and as a jump
off point
for um your next video heather did stop
making these three mistakes
on camera mistakes powerful right
um 2.5 million views advice for new
youtubers
10 mistakes new youtubers make 10
mistakes
strong in the thumbnail there and and i
want to encourage you consider re
making some videos too right because
when you have a video that's done well
this is three years old it's been doing
great
we redid it about a year ago and instead
of 10 we did 21 common mistakes that new
youtubers should avoid and let's let it
grow
like it continues to grow it continues
to get views and remember youtube is a
marathon and not a sprint not just in
terms of your breakthrough
but in terms of i hope you're posting
videos today like a farmer plant seeds
that you're planting the seeds today for
the harvest you want to reap tomorrow
so when you put out smart videos today
that have long-term strategy they can
keep getting views for weeks months and
years to come
that's the mistakes and i want to
encourage you to do title combos
okay and so um that could be like this
video
two million views how to come up with a
youtube name
as a how-to three tips and mistakes to
avoid
so not only am i gonna learn how to come
up with a youtube name
i'm gonna get some tips i'm also gonna
get some mistakes to avoid
that's a lot of value packed in the
title remember your youtube video title
makes
a promise and then your goal is to
deliver on that promise
in the content and so here's some ideas
and uh if you appreciate this kind of
content um
i would appreciate if you hit the like
button because uh here's some mistakes
titles
hashtags mistakes that are hurting your
instagram growth
advice for new youtubers 10 mistakes new
youtubers make
common new mom mistakes and how to fix
them
five investing mistakes to avoid in your
20s
top 10 fashion mistakes you need to
avoid
top 10 fashion mistakes you need to
avoid for women
over 40. come on let's get crazy
right on coffee with kennel and so those
are some ideas
and remember today's episode is brought
to you by the youtube starter kit if you
want to see
all 15 of the title formulas that's just
one of the assets inside of the whole
starter kit
we've got multiple thumbnail uh
resources in there
more video ideas 51 video ideas to jump
start your channel
51 many making video ideas it's one of
my favorite things we're doing this year
because it's over 90
off for the holidays tubestarterkit.com
free ticket
to our four hour new year youtube
strategy workshop
that is happening on january 2nd on a
saturday you'll be able to watch the
replay
uh if you did not if you're not able to
make it
all the details link in the description
down below tubestarterkit.com
question of the day what is the title of
your most
viewed video what's the title and what
can you learn
from the title of your most viewed video
remember success leaves clues
and so post that title um the link
should be coming your way for you to
join
coffee with kannel if it hasn't already
and
i'm excited to take a couple questions
today
but i hope you're doing well um my
name's sean cannell
this is our think marketing channel and
um we do a weekly
think marketing podcast every tuesday
have you been listening to the podcast
we're in a four-part series that i hope
you're enjoying there
what else is happening we do a show
every other week coffee with cannell one
week and then think marketing live show
with heather taurus every other
week or whatever it comes out to be i
hope you're subscribed if you're not
subscribed
and uh if you want to jump on the stream
today
uh the link is in the live chat and i
would love to answer your questions
if you've got just a text question put
four question marks before and after the
question
and i would love to answer that for you
yeah anthony
we have a podcast it's called um
the uh think marketing podcast it's on
spotify google
apple and the video podcast lives here
on
um the channel and so um if you haven't
subscribed
wherever you listen to podcasts
definitely um
check it out and so uh this is the think
marketing podcast over on spotify
and then if you check out the channel if
you go to playlists
you've got the podcast right here so
we're
44 episodes in and the latest episode it
always comes out on a tuesday
so we just released part three in a
three-part series this on the right side
you can see the most recent episode with
heather's and no me
no miss episode so if you're subscribed
on the channel here
and if you are um turning on
notifications here
then that is a great uh
way to make sure you don't miss the
podcast and then we do this live show as
well
um let me know what one of your top
titles was the fit cosplay my highest
video is called pikachu workout
that makes sense uh you know probably
people
that um i and thanks for being here it's
good to see you again i think we did a
channel
review with you once tying into trends
um
tying into maybe somebody that wants to
get in shape while also having fun with
something they're passionate about so
that's a really powerful one
how important is having a studio set up
it's not about your resources it's about
your resourcefulness
so it's nice to have a battle station a
place where you can set up and record
but never underestimate the power of
just getting started with what you have
your smartphone
putting it on there's a really good
video uh
called um like video hacks
or smartphone hacks that uh that five
free smartphone hacks
so this is one of those videos where
omar will crush your excuses
and you could see that like that is a
paper cup
as a tripod to just put your smartphone
on a couple boxes
on your couch so it really is not about
your resources it's about your
resourcefulness
as you grow as you maybe get momentum as
you
are working at your day job like i was
doing you know i'm a small town kid
college dropout
um grew up in marysville washington and
went to arlington
high school in arlington washington and
i worked at red robin waiting tables for
10 years
i used money from tips from waiting
tables to invest in my side business
which was youtube and video
and eventually like a wedding production
you know
kind of video production company that i
built so
yes invest in whatever your dream is
invest in your gear invest in your setup
but don't wait until you get the
quote unquote right camera there's no
right camera start creating today
punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face and press
record
today um what if your most viewed video
is not something you think you continue
can continue to do on your channel
well if you can't continue to do it then
then don't keep doing it
um maybe you can continue to do it
oftentimes
we will find that the content we're
creating is maybe different than our
most popular video which tells us a
couple things
are we creating the right content or
i've know some people have made those
videos unlisted i know you want to keep
getting the views but remember you never
want to upload a video your subscribers
didn't subscribe for
so if your top viewed video is about
gardening and it has a million views and
people subscribe for gardening and you
no longer talk about gardening
it's kind of like hurting you because
people subscribe and they're like wait
you don't talk about that anymore
so this is a strategy conversation but
your top success leaves clues why is it
getting views what can you learn from it
what could you continue to do
with your top video consider that
um how can i use the versa strategy in
my niche for personal
development really good question and
then we'll bring some folks on
for coffee with kennel today versus
strategy for personal development
um uh so in personal development we
learn about mindset
right so it's a fixed mindset versus a
growth mindset
at the verses fixed mindset and look at
this
four years ago now consider content
formats
this video has 2.1 million views versus
strategy
my god um you know so that's
your i want to encourage you that
you got to dive deep in your niche i
personal development's a personal
passion and hobby
you don't want to see under my desk i
got 400 books
i got 3 000 books at my house and in my
various shelves and libraries that i
have
in my garage and everywhere um but i'm
obsessed with it so
so what are the what are the verses it
could be the versus concepts
um you know different leadership
theories different personal development
theories
it could be um you know if you get into
personal development personal finance
it could be like dave ramsey versus
robert kiyosaki or versus grant cardone
or versus oprah versus graham stefan
and you break down the difference
between their beliefs uh
and this video has got 133 000
views versus strategy and so
um that's just a couple ideas of how you
could use it in personal
personal development maybe get creative
think outside of the box a little bit
and uh that's something you could
consider man we got evan on the show
today evan welcome back
what's up it's so good to be back man i
do have another question though and i'm
i'm sure you can answer it no problem
remind everybody uh who you are what you
do and then fire off the question
all right so i do well i've been on
youtube for about two and a half years
now i started doing a video a week at
the beginning of 2019.
um since then i've done at least a video
a week maybe one week off out of
that but i've made up for it in other
videos and
i've mostly been doing like musical
stuff musicians praise and worship team
tips and tools for teens
is kind of my catch phrase and so i
would help churches out with praise and
worship
doing interviews and that kind of stuff
but recently after the seven day youtube
challenge i started helping out with my
church's youtube channel
and that blew up i mean just crossed 129
000 subscribers with just a little bit
of vr
vra training definitely worth it if in
case you're wondering out there whether
or not you should do it
and we just crossed 11 million views too
uh talking about hopping a trend train
we hopped the election which was a
pretty big trend so we were able to get
on that train
but yeah and but my channel is
it's kind of i don't know leveled out
with the views and i mean the guitar
tutorials i would do do great but then
the lighting videos i would do
do like spectacular i did a video a few
months ago about
and actually these led lights i'm using
here sixty dollars for a two pack
and i think it's 60 watts but i use the
affiliate marketing tips you gave me
i've made hundreds of dollars probably
at least four hundred dollars already
just from that one video
and so i'm thinking that's the direction
i should start going the tech side of
things for churches
and the social media side but i'm not
sure
like should i just switch over and start
going full force in that direction or
should i slowly transition like how can
i transition from the praise and worship
what's happening in the musical side of
things to
that social media side of things because
that's what i'm passionate about what i
can make more money on
100 so the conversation today
is i think there's a little bit of
strategy there's a little bit of time
management
um a couple things i would encourage you
is uh let's just start with the
practical
success leaves clues um
what's your end goal that's a great
question to ask
you know is your end goal to create the
videos you're most passionate about and
express those or is it also a hybrid
of being able to fund your ministry
because if you could get to completely
paying your bills
paying for you know a wedding in the
future i'm assuming you're not married
you know what i mean buying it
like if you could do all that kind of
stuff um that's
that's part of our dream and think media
is to help 10 000 people go full time
so the monetization is a practical path
and the question is how do i
marry the monetization with the impact i
want to make we want people to do
high impact and high profit yeah so
but i think that you it's a lot of
self-awareness and it's a lot of looking
internally and
it's not a black-and-white issue it's a
tension to be managed
to say i got to pay the bills i need
money for the mission
but what there's also the content i want
to create and it's not all about vanity
mess
metrics and what we'll just get views
and what'll just make money it's a mix
so what's your end goal though paint the
vision for me so
kind of i'm still trying to figure that
out of course i'm still in high school
so i don't
you know know where i'll be in five
years from now but
um and how i've been able to help out my
church and my pastor
i'd like other churches actually all
over america have been asking us how did
you do this
and i would like to help more churches
do what we've done
and because a lot of people think that
youtube is a lost world for the church
and you know it's
to me it's a mission field just like
africa is a mission field
and i want to help as many churches as
possible reach as many people as
possible
and i think that could be considered my
goal to be able to
do that but also to fund um getting more
tech for our ministry to do more reviews
also to do more things with our live
streams do more interviews
with people so i think that's more of my
goal
and in the future maybe i'll have a
ministry one day and i'd like to be able
to fund that
from my youtube channel as well and go
through college
yeah i mean i think you got a lot more
clarity than you think and i love your
heart and i love
i mean i'm sure a lot of people and
shout out evan in the
comments and chat like you got a lot of
clarity man you're getting success
already you have momentum already
um it is not any one of those things all
those things can exist altogether
um meaning and i even reflect
on when i was building my career
taking steps i think every every aspect
of the seasons you're in right now
matter
the things you're learning with working
with your church how you're deploying
this information for them
how you'll help others and go in and
help consult and
educate them what you'll teach on
youtube what you're learning from niche
videos about stage lighting
what you're learning like it's just all
part of a big thing i want to encourage
you is just to like really embrace the
journey and be patient and
you can't do everything all at once but
you can do everything over time
like the way you know we often say it is
you can do anything but you can't do
everything
but you can do everything just not all
at once i mean what grade
that's good uh i'm in let's see 10th
grade i had to think about that
i mean dear god bro i just turned 37.
so i mean what's gonna happen in your
life
over the next 20 or 15 years i should
say
there's just a lot of different time to
deploy different types of content to
answer different questions and different
types of videos
a way to summarize things is i think in
regards to youtube
it's it's both you should go deep and
wide
wide is maybe a practical tech video
that reaches more people but keep in
mind people that discover that and that
it ranks for
may not even be into church stuff and
they may not even want to subscribe
they may just stop by watch the video
say evan's dope thanks for the tips buy
a product
but here's what's cool that video has a
practical purpose
it is going to help you pay your bills
eventually and for your wedding someday
and it's going to help you you know buy
that ring because those things are
expensive
and so it's going to help you like
accomplish financial goals
depth though is not getting overly in
one
extreme of just only being like well if
i just go all in i could turn this into
a money machine
unless that's the goal nothing wrong
with that because if you're like i'm
going to use this youtube channel to
fund
this over here so i have autonomy and it
takes me 20 hours a week to do this
and eventually earn 510k a month and so
now i got all this freedom to do what i
want over here
so a lot of it has to just do with
reverse engineering and getting clear on
what's the purpose what's the purpose of
this next upload what's the purpose of
the channel
but i think it's both that could go wide
and you always cast your vision
and remember what we teach in like vra
about bridge marketing
deliver the video of the tech review
deliver the information on the tech
review
up front let people know about it and
then at the end you might go and look
man my name is evan
and really my heart is helping church
leaders
and some people are going to go oh i'm
out of here you know like what
like which is great because now you're
polarizing in terms of who your
subscribers are
but they still might have stopped by and
got value from the video and they're
like oh i respect that but like that's
not my vibe
so they don't click subscribe but some
do that's then the depth and then you
might do a live stream
you might do a q a you might do a social
media strategy video and it doesn't do
as well
as the tech review but it doesn't matter
because depth and width matters
lots of youth matters but also
relationships like you and me hanging
out and talking like this matters too
and
you know what i'm saying this all is not
going to be like super viral or viewed
by a lot of people because
it's a longer conversation of us you
know you get the idea
it's it's both it's not either or it's
both
and in terms of i think your video
content mix
and then just giving yourself patience
because bro you are killing it
and it's just about tweaking constantly
i love your questions
these are questions we ask at think
media all the time how should we pivot
our stuff
what topics should we hit this will be
most popular but should we also cover
this
where do we want to go next how does
this tie into our vision for one year
two years three years from now
um i want to encourage you you got a lot
more clarity than you think but clarity
is a lifelong journey for all of us
even when we're really clear i think we
should always be seeking
additional clarity because that's how we
live uh
that is how we have a life well lived
that's called intentional living
that's called life by design and life by
strategy
and not just floating down the current
but choosing to swim
to a particular destination that's
really good thank you for that
um looking at myself pretty much like
every day i don't feel like i have
that much clarity but you saying that
really helps thank you for that so
just you're like go all in on it
just go full force i mean yeah and
and you're so young and you're doing
great
the more you experience as i land the
plane
i am who i am in my career and my life
and my skill set
because of um
doing tasting a lot of different things
now here's
people say you need to focus and niche
down
i would agree with that because i would
say if i was trying to be a pro golfer
a pro worship leader a pro youtuber
uh you know a pro lego builder if i was
trying to do all that stuff that'd
probably be too much
but inside a domain you've kind of
clarified your domain i love social
media
i love helping churches communicate i
love the tech side i love the music side
that's all like that's in the same world
a similar path as me as you know
and so there's actually a book and it's
you know there's extremes that everybody
makes
uh i'm looking it up here but people
have all these extremes
where it's like you should get super
focused and then some people are like
no actually you shouldn't be as focused
i think there's something to
um having diversity in your experience
here's the book it's called
range and um
it's a super well good selling book and
i actually think
that in 2021 in today's
world range why generalists
triumph in a specialized world and
that's not to get it confused for people
that are like awesome now my youtube
channel
can you know just be about 48 different
things
but what it talks about is
um uh how in different areas of business
the world's so complex in the world so
dynamic now that it's nice to get
sharpened by different projects and when
i go back
in different experiences and it turns
you into a more dynamic individual
here's why this is important
if anything's super linear it's going to
get replaced by robots
if anything is super just a plus b
equals c
all the time that will be automated by
an ai that'll eventually kill us like
terminator
so time travel will have to come back to
you know
save uh john connor you get the whole
thing
and it'll be fine because sarah connor
of course okay
terminator but ultimately uh
we need to be dynamic individuals
well-versed
individuals and to play contradiction
there's the phrase jack of all trades
that phrase originated in europe around
butler's and people don't finish the
phrase
it's jack of all trades master of all of
them
oh come on that's good it was these
butlers who they're like i can cook
i can sew i can uh fix change the oil in
master's car i can you know
get i could do the landscaping like i
could do it all
like and that takes time building up
your skill set i want to encourage you
stay in a domain because you know the
domain you want to dominate you know the
domain you want to serve
but like do a lot of things in that
domain so i think about i've shot videos
for conferences
i've done consulting i've been in the
weirdest situations with like some weird
dude in like a room and i'm like how did
i get here i'm in like tennessee
well you know just like doing a
consulting job and you know
talking to my wife like how who what am
i doing but like the flying there
the talking they're trying to solve the
problems to trying to please the client
the shooting a wedding video the
shooting of seattle hip-hop music artist
video
the doing niche channels it all made me
into the dynamic i would argue
media person that i am today so
to not be overly judgmental on yourself
about
like having to be so clear like you have
all this clarity but you got to play
within that clarity
to develop greater range if anybody
wants to check out the book range
uh that's in the live chat and we'll put
a link in the description below as well
powerful book uh and uh a powerful
message i think needed as we go into
2021.
that's so good thank you so much
hopefully soon i'll get to meet you one
day
when you call in all the 10 000
entrepreneurs that made a full-time
living doing what they love so thank you
i know you're going to be there evan i
appreciate you thanks for coming on
coffee with kennel today
see you later range
generalist triumph why generalist
triumph in a specialized
world plenty of experts argue that
anyone who wants to develop a skill play
an instrument or lead in their field
should start early focus intensely
and rack up as many hours of deliberate
practice as possible
if you dabble or delay you'll never
catch up to people who got a head start
but a closer look at research of the
world's top performers
found professional athletes to noble lot
don't know the word shows that early
specialization is the
exception and not the rule david epstein
examines the world's most successful
athletes artists musicians inventors and
forecasters and scientists
and he discovered that in most fields
especially those that are complex and
unpredictable
generalist not specialists are primed to
excel
what is youtube it is complex and it is
unpredictable
if you want to build a media company you
want to work from home you want to write
your own checks
you want to make a business on your own
terms you want to adapt to the algorithm
adapt to your competitors adapt to
what's happening adapt to new technology
adapt to things changing adapt to an
ever shifting world
adapt to change change change change all
around us
the author of this book discovered that
in
fields that are complex and
unpredictable the field you want to be
in
generalist not specialists are primed to
excel range my friends is the book
and i'm glad that evan triggered me
bringing that up and um
something to check out if you want link
in the description below
that's my affiliate link come on you
know how we do it over here come on you
gotta know
if you click that even if you don't buy
the book if you're gonna do some
christmas shopping you know you just
check stop by through our affiliate link
first i'd appreciate it hey it's coffee
with candle today hey what's your name
what's your channel and uh what do you
do
hi sean i'm emily um my channel is
called e-cop shop
and i have an etsy shop and it's
basically um
around that however i do dabble in
some other videos i just started about a
month ago but it's all within
the same aesthetic that is awesome
and uh how can i help today
i was just wondering in regards to the
title what do you
put in your thumbnail um that differs
from your title do you put the same
exact
words do you put like a little
clickbaity something
what do you do really really good
question and thanks so much for coming
on with coffee with kennel
uh i wanna also encourage you great job
at just jumping in
starting out posting videos um and
punching fear in the face
348 subscribers in a really short time
is awesome great great job and um
and so in terms of thumbnails
a couple tips a you already know
thumbnails are a big deal and you want
to do your best
to um think about thumbnails that pop
think about how you can make thumbnails
stand out a couple
ideas number one you may not need words
in your thumbnails
so i just made four thumbnails
uh on the think media side of things so
we use slack
and here they are and i uh and i'll give
you some examples of the way i think
about them
one um a very uh
small no one has a video coming out on
five youtube tools
free tools youtube speaks for itself
um next in this case i
would argue you shouldn't repeat your
title
words in your thumbnail so the title of
this video i think
is how youtube recommendations work
and algorithm hacks is more like oh i
want to click on algorithm hacks or i
want to click on hacks
plus the visuals and everything but
saying that
your title already says it so you don't
necessarily need to say the same thing
in your thumbnail
but maybe you just say one word in your
thumbnail maybe you just say
because for example you might say try
this like that makes me want to click so
your title might be like
how to uh diy
something in your apartment and a cool
thumbnail
image captures attention and it says try
this try what it makes me want to read
the title
so it doesn't have to necessarily be
like how to do diy
curtains and then the title that's the
title and then the thumbnail says how to
do diy curtains well that's just an echo
there's no need to repeat yourself
so think of it like a dance your title
is doing some of the job your thumbnails
doing some of the job
and they're working together and think
about the viewer's experience
on that feed being like try what reads
title
title is interesting makes me want to
click and
then they click through and the video
starts let me show you couple others
go ahead you have a follow-up i think
that people look at the thumbnail first
or the title first
i absolutely think they look at the
thumbnail first okay
um and i think that uh what kind of
content do you make here
let's see obviously like stickers and
etsy stuff but
i'm still trying to figure it out
so is stickers is it like custom
stickers
yeah i make my own on edge i can't speak
for everybody but i'll tell you
how my brain works live so how to make
custom stickers would you make a video
like that i just filmed it
okay so i'm gonna say at home and i'm
gonna hit enter
and here's how my brain works so first
thing i did was i i read
as an american left to right i read how
to make stickers
in that case it's so simple such a few
words such a clean thumbnail
that first video is pretty amazing grabs
my attention then i look over
how to make stickers from home nice
tutorial
tutorial is a strong word because i want
a whole explanation maybe not just some
surface information but i have a feeling
that's going to be step by step
next there are some kind of words in
there but mostly that's just kind of
beauty cool here's the promise i can do
that
i could get that result i don't really
read the three methods
but i definitely look at that first and
then my eyes go to the right
three ways to make diy stickers using
stuff at home
oh cool now i potentially want to click
over here i also i read 2020 update
first which is strong because notice
there's like no other words there
but now i'm playing towards he's playing
towards current
like oh okay this is some new
information are those some of the
results i can get and then i read
how to make pro quality waterproof
snickers stickers now
the cool thing is both are going to
maybe still help me make my decision
because depending on how niche my
problem is i might go
that's not the answer like if it was
like how to cook steak i might be like
okay
uh how to cook the perfect steak that
looks pretty interesting gets my
attention
but then maybe it's also like well i
need it
to i can't i don't have a grill or i
don't have a paint like that right you
know this actually i guess gives me all
of them i'm like oh
i have a waffle iron i'm gonna do it in
a waffle iron so maybe it's even the
method does that make sense there's like
different details
so all to say is um i think that
ultimately it definitely is thumbnail
grabbing attention and then
hopefully creating like an open loop of
curiosity
and then leading to the next thing this
is pretty literal this came out today
change your name but this one comes out
a while in a while
no words and then the title is should
you start
two youtube channels so
hopefully the minimalism in terms of
there's not too much busyness
what's happening there my eyes point
direction and
my eyes point towards the title as do
the youtube
play buttons so it actually starts from
sort of like a
like read this way if i'm pointing the
right way which actually should be this
way
read this i think if i'm doing it right
uh read this way
look all the way through and read the
title should you start two youtube
channels
and then of course my subscriber or
if the video ranks and does well then
they go
what's that about should you start two
channels that is the question i'm asking
the click-through starts in the video
begins right
great thank you so much that answered my
question completely and more
awesome well i appreciate you so much
best of luck happy holidays and thanks
so much for coming on coffee with kennel
thank you
my friends if you're getting value today
hit the like button and uh that was a
fun
um thumbnail session as a reminder
today's episode is brought to you by
the youtube starter kit that is right my
friends the youtube starter kit is 90
off right now and in our create awesome
thumbnails training we have a recording
from our growth video live conference
um that's really cool and we have some
deep dive training on youtube strategy
we also have um let me get in here
we've got uh the this has never been
released anywhere else
i do a two hour training now this is
only if you use photoshop
but you'll learn a lot and eventually
and i go through
from photography excuse me through
lightroom through photoshop
all the way through a lot of strategies
that i think about in terms of
thumbnails
anyways it's 90 off and you get all that
all the other things it's pretty dang
cool and so this is what it looks like
inside just so you can see it
so this is the starter kit you can watch
if you go to the thumbnails
10 custom thumbnails to supercharge your
channels the how to create awesome
youtube thumbnails
training and and then the advanced
training so this guy an hour and 34
minutes
and i kind of break down my photography
process
how i process the photos how i think
about
researching the thumbnails a lot of
different kind of cool things
and that's just again one feature uh it
even goes into then the strategy of
titling it and
releasing the video so anyways link in
the description below if you haven't
checked that out
and the new year's workshop that we're
doing as well so you get a ticket to our
youtube strategy workshop
january 2nd 9 a.m pacific time to 1 pm
4 hours long there's going to be time to
plan your videos
you'll leave with a year's worth of
content ideas
you'll learn leave with some of our
newest strategies inside look at what
we're doing
at all of our channels to win in 2021
a lot of it is going to be some quick
tips from tony and omar
heather's going to be training a lot
about productivity will you be honest
with me and tell me in the chat or in
the comments
is it hard to get youtube stuff done i
mean to manage time
to manage school to manage work to
juggle the kids
come on i got 11 week old to get your
videos done
to script them shoot them edit them
upload them thumbnail them description
them
put them out there share on social start
over oh my goodness
it goes on and on to bat shoot the
videos you forgot to turn your
microphone on
you just wasted an hour of talking with
no audio
you want to rip your hair out and throw
your camera across the yard
but you're you don't want to ruin your
m50 so you decide to
compose yourself and shoot the batch
over
and you learned your lesson to actually
turn the microphone on next time
only people who know how painful that is
know how painful that is
and can feel the tears dripping from my
heart from how many times i've done that
look it's so really crushing in 2021 you
got to get your time management right
you got to get your productivity right
and
we don't presume to speak into your
whole life because we want to help you
with youtube and went on youtube
but let's be honest it affects your
whole life because if you can't manage
your calendar your schedule
get ahead in your productivity even get
ahead in your
emotional mastery and even the mindset
and overcoming the fear of getting on
camera and all that kind of stuff
we're here to help you win on youtube
we're obsessed with you getting to your
goals with youtube
and creating a full-time living doing
what you love while making a difference
in the world with youtube
but there's a lot of aspects and so i'm
so excited because heather three kids
church responsibilities business
responsibilities side channel
client work different stuff that she
does and just stay insane is just going
to be sharing
her time management calendar blocking um
routines and in a training the podcast
episode this week which you'll enjoy
it came out tuesday the five hour
youtube work week yeah you could get
youtube done in five hours or less a
week
she explains how so you can watch that
she's gonna go deep in that training for
40 minutes
and break down the five hour youtube
work week now if you want to crank that
up to 10 or 15.
amazing but all that's happening can't
even wait
youtube strategy workshop 97 ticket it's
a bonus
at youtubestarterkit.com so you get a
ticket
to the um to that event
and it's going to be amazing so
let's keep it going we got marcus back
on the show today
marcus how you doing been a minute since
i see you give me an update what's
happening with your life your channels
you had multiple channels in the past
are you focused right now on one channel
what's happening
hey bro we are you sound like you're in
the distant land
of the wrong microphone selected or
something
any better it's not i don't
i think it's i think it's probably
maybe reconnect the mic hang out and see
if there's a you know
stream yard select audio source
it's so faint bro work on that for a
second and then we'll
uh we'll come we'll bring it back uh did
i see jonathan's camera go dark like
what is happening
hey if you got a question drop it in the
comments
uh let me know uh i'm gonna bring on
uh jpz what's up man i hope your audio
works
uh tell me about your channel and uh how
can i help
uh mostly uh my is about uh
different kind of actual stuff and
uh it's mostly about hot sauce
related and stuff like that
and all i'm pretty much is uh
honestly doing is
ask asking for more people
like like you to help out more
people like like littler channels and
stuff
yeah that one right there got it got it
so what's your question today
my question is um uh
is like all of this uh stuff
uh like what can i do
to help out my uh like
people that are watching my channel
like what should i like do
to um grow more on youtube
yeah bro great question and thanks for
being on coffee with kennel today
you know this channel reminds me a lot
of when i was kind of getting started
and that was a lot of experimentation
and um a lot of like
statements like i'm going geocaching at
night um
you know i am playing among us
um i'm at bishop castle guys
you know um i'm unboxing my merch
uh in fact there's a lot of even i in
your title
which on the one hand i want you to be
in five things i like
to do five things i like to eat
now i know when watching youtube uh
when sometimes we watch influencers or
whatever it can seem like it's about
them
and some of them it's a small percentage
but they have
success but i think the the move is to
think about
pivoting now i'm not calling you selfish
but we talk just to to make the point
there's selfish content and there's
service
content five things i like to do
is about me like hey do you want to
listen to like me
because if you want to like watch me and
study me
and and watch what i like then watch
this video
well how far can that really go imagine
if you flipped it
five ways
to save money on your taxes now that's
probably not something
advice you're going to be giving out but
now it's about the viewer
it's about helping the viewer solve a
problem it's about helping a particular
audience on youtube solve a problem
and a lot of this um
again just people it's kind of vlog
people watching your stuff
but here's what i want to encourage you
with is you're creating
and this reminds me of my journey i just
was creating a lot of videos
getting used to creating videos getting
used to filming getting used to
uploading
getting used to making thumbnails you're
not really making thumbnails so
start working on making thumbnails and
uploading custom thumbnails learn a
software like canva
or photoshop or something like that um
and
and and just continuing to grow so the
to summarize the tips um number one
just keep creating okay number two
while you're creating though think about
now pivoting and trying to figure out
who's this channel going to be for what
problem does it
solve even if it's entertainment because
sometimes people think well
does it have to be like just a how-to
channel no even if it's an entertainment
channel
is it the most entertaining
among us gameplay videos is it the
is it the official secrets and easter
eggs uncovered channel
how does it serve other people and shift
it away from being
less about you or in a way not about you
at all and
really about the viewer if you can get
obsessed with the viewer
think about even who the viewer is and
and let me be honest man i'm grateful
you're here you're a young guy
like this is you might be like this
stuff's hard to figure out man it sounds
complex yeah
it's a journey you know and so just to
again to sort of encourage you
literally when i started my channel on
my it was my sean kennel channel i kind
of had similar content
i had my phone and i i started kind of
just talking to the camera on a webcam
but i would just like film stuff like
crazy las vegas tram ride
and i went to vegas i at the time lived
in seattle
and like filmed a tram ride
you know what i mean but like at the end
of the day especially going into 2021
what even is this like this is just this
has like nothing to do with anything you
know
maybe somebody wants to like actually
watch the las vegas tram
but then it's starting to get so i just
like you
i was just kind of experimenting
learning
posting but the final tip i probably
give you is stay connected to think
marketing
watch other channels about business
marketing
about communication and level up because
bro i've been on a journey
for 20 years now and and it sounds like
and it looks like you're kind of like
just getting started
so it's definitely a journey enjoy the
journey commit to keep
i started seven months ago seven months
ago i started so
it is like a journey to get like people
to notice you
and stuff so technically that's why
i i found i found your channel out and
that's why i was pretty much like
interested in your channel because
you're actually
pointing out to people how to maybe get
this
and this stuff like that so that's kind
of what channels i
kind of like too but like when i started
i wanted to kind of
be like a hot slash challenge maker or
something
and it i recognized maybe i should
experiment on
different stuff not like maybe one thing
but then i can settle down on
one thing when i'm done experimenting
you said it exactly right i think that
you experiment first and you narrow down
as you go especially at the stage that
you're at
and i love that she said you've been
going for seven months i've been going
for
60 x you know longer like 100 x longer
in terms
so yeah just enjoy the journey keep
posting videos but keep learning and
leveling up
and hopefully you get value from this
community in communities like this on
youtube man thanks for coming on the
show today
thank you appreciate ya
all right smash like if you're having
fun on coffee with candler today let's
see how marcus's audio is
how are we feeling about this sounds
great you sound amazing
you look amazing how's it going what
what's going on
headset sounds amazing that's cool um
yes a little update so last time we
spoke i was considering starting a
personal finance channel and i ended up
doing it it was called money with marcus
but i'm not feeling it anymore so
it was actually really cool to try it
and it kind of helped me refocus my
original channel okay
um which was which was a really good
good experience and i have a very
specific question for you about
my main channel here and it's about
leveraging
search results so i've been able to rank
several videos on a very
niche topic and that topic is hybrid
meetings and hybrid meetings are
meetings where you have people in the
room together and others
join online remotely via zoom it's a
very
non-competitive topic there are not very
many videos about it but it's a hot new
trend because
these are the kind of meetings that
we're going to be having i think in in
2020 and 2021.
i agree so the so the question is
because i rank very highly in youtube
for that
term hybrid meetings and also on google
how can i leverage that to for
monetization and i want to tell you what
i've done so far so of course i have
affiliate links in the videos already i
just got accepted to the amazon partner
program
amazon associates i have approached
brands
for potential brand deals and i have
driven people to my mailing list so
those are the three things that i've
done and i kind of want to
how should i leverage the fact that i'm
usually ranked number one for the term
hybrid meetings very specific yeah yeah
i mean
first of all too love what you're doing
and
such a great example i want to just
encourage
everybody watching this the world is
always changing
and you go oh it's too complex it's too
competitive it's hard to stand out
people have already taken all the topics
well not when the topics didn't even
exist first of all it wasn't a pandemic
then there wasn't even a need for zoom
at first and then a lot of people did
zoom
and then there's now the need for hybrid
meetings and you jumped on it quick
brilliant strategy great way uh great
job of
acting quick and jumping on it um
additionally i think you're already
uh really doing well i have just
basically
one idea for you um my friend jeremy
he says uh you do what's called nested
keywords and a nested keyword is
if you were to say something like
youtube basics like you say something
something something powerful title
youtube basics something something
something powerful title
youtube basics and that becomes a
nested keyword so i think you're already
doing it but to continue
to put like hybrid meetings and to think
about that you may have already done
this but the next
10 videos you make maybe not all
released in a row
but like best webcams or best technology
you know
search term for hybrid meetings and then
um
you know this is how to set up your room
so i'm sure you're kind of doing that
certain one of those videos
would connect maybe more directly to
affiliate marketing
um but you're already doing this right
getting the checklist out there smart i
assume in the checklist there's probably
some affiliate links is that true
in the checklist there are no affiliate
links because it's pdf and
amazon does not allow links and pdfs and
pdfs
um okay so true so
um but you're building your email list
yeah correct
so um you got that going you've got
these affiliate links
the one strategy i would go for is
i would leverage being the king of a
small pond
and start talking to anybody in this
space
it just makes me think like it seems
crazy
but if we sort of look at it from this
perspective
if you kind of went from forgive me here
but from just unknown
to the number one expert in planet earth
on hybrid meetings
that's the kind of world we live in i
think that becomes interesting
even if it's a small niche what is that
to certain software or certain plugins
or certain
360 degree microphones what is that
how interesting could that be to them
that you find out who those people are
follow them on linkedin dm with them on
linkedin
email them directly and do a biz dev
strategy of like hey
you know i'm creating content i you know
i have a niche channel
but this is obviously where things are
going i see what you do in your software
company
and i'm wondering if there'd want to be
some kind of a collaboration it actually
makes me think
we just got a report from somebody who's
part of our community
three thousand subscribers two thousand
subscribers
and um he's somewhere international
i wish i remember his name and he has
two main
brand deals through his college and he
basically
has basically has like one sugar daddy
paying
him to be full-time he's full-time on
youtube with like less than 5 000
subscribers i think less than 4
000. is that oliver from finland oliver
yeah yeah the oliver model
is what i'm recommending right because
does that make sense when you
you might just you might link up with
one brand and you're like why don't i
have a huge channel
but you're like bros let's go 50k
for the year let's go 100k for the year
whatever
and you might be able to reverse
engineer a year's worth
and if if now you think about it from
this standpoint
that deal might include um
video production for them some editing
for them they use some of your content
and they put that out on facebook as an
ad and some different things
but it also goes on your channel and you
make that alliance
this is the oliver method is
[Laughter]
is a legit thing like so many people
watching this
need to really think about that as the
play you
take your niche small channel you
strategically align with basically
one sugar daddy brand and you go full
time
and it's not necessarily going to be a
walk in the park your channel might
meaning your channel might have to align
to where yes they're on
they're the annual sponsor of your
channel plus
you have some other video editing to do
for them plus
how deep do you really want to go and
niching down with them so maybe do two
videos a week but one is theirs
and again it might become like a new
employer in a way
because you may end up having to do you
know 20 hours 25 30 hours work for them
a week
but now you work from home and make
75 000 and maybe it doesn't start there
but maybe
you know and they and they just pay you
per month
and you are they basically fund you to
also grow your channel
because if you upload two videos a week
one is whatever you want to do and the
other one is like
the deep dive it's the hybrid meeting
show
where everybody learns about hybrid
media brought to you by sugar daddy
sponsor
the hybrid meeting q a hour it's it's
the oliver method bro
right he's full-time he sent us a
message he's like he's like this is
crazy
i do this full-time i'm on my own terms
and it's like the school and like the
other part of the school that like
pay him full just it's the sugar daddy
brands
that is a really good idea
so far what i when i when i've been able
to get from a couple of brands who are
in this space i've been able to get a
free product and
i was kind of thinking of i have
contacted all them i only had a
successful contact with two of them
but maybe it's better to focus on one of
them at this sugar daddy this is an
interesting idea
and because the company the companies in
this space they make speaker phones they
make
video cameras that follow you around the
and these kind of
hybrid meeting setups they can be
hundreds of thousands or they can be
consumer level stuff
so there's actually an interesting
growth study i like it
my man i like the sugar daddy that's
what i'm going to put in the in the
email subject line for sure sugar daddy
proposal
the sugar i love it bro well hey let me
know how that works and here's what's
cool
like you got affiliate like it's been
cool to watch your progression
and i mean have you been getting value
thanks for being like so consistently
here at coffee with kennel has this show
been valuable
in in more ways than one of course i i
love all the tips and i love all the all
the interaction
but i'm also now doing live streams
usually every sunday
and i'm basically ripping off your whole
concept in my live streams
like the thing that you do at this at
the top of the stream you start out with
one powerful tip
before you even introduce yourself i'm
gonna do that at my next live stream
to really deliver value at the very
beginning of the video that is such a
powerful night and i've seen you
do it twice now yesterday and today and
i was like that is that is such a
brilliant move
uh so i mean i'm also getting like
inspirational from just the way
you guys do it massive value massive
value well i appreciate you
thanks so much uh for sharing that and
uh
someone says what is your channel so
shout it out as i uh put it on screen
here
it's uh marcosepolis just my name and
originally started with communication
tips from a comedian but now it's just
mostly communication tips a lot of zoom
advice but also
if you do want to take my comedy courses
or some videos about that
comedyforbeginners.com but mostly it's
about the zoom advice there
marcus i appreciate you man thanks so
much for coming on and happy holidays
thank you happy holidays to you as well
see you next time
coffee with candle crew hey what are you
drinking let me know shout me out i got
a little bit of coffee
here uh
brandywine coffee roasters i ordered
this coffee during black friday it was
shipped
many states away into my fellow grinder
it just went through my aeropress and
it's so good
and so uh who is oliver
with the sugar daddy so tina
such a great question we're like it's
kind of like a
we're speaking in limericks um but the
simple idea is
oliver has been on coffee with cannell
and he
uh recently sent us a message that he's
full-time now
and he was making videos for his college
he was a student
but the college basically hired him
essentially like
one brand deal to kind of be like a
spokesperson via his youtube channel i
don't think it was the only thing he had
to do on his youtube channel
to give you another example is you know
she's she's definitely further along one
of our video ranking academy students
um is named uh nicole
and um she just crossed a hundred
thousand subscribers got that silver
play button
and she is um
able to do whatever videos she wants but
i want to see
it says includes paid promotion she
basically
uh if my knowledge serves me correctly
got a brand deal
with one brand and it's an annual
contract
makes sense and so um
i don't know which one it is but you get
the idea and so it was some kind of
because they were kind of having her be
like a spokesperson or an ongoing
content creator for them
it's not the only thing she does on her
channel now mind you might go oh she has
100 000 subscribers we're all of her and
we just were joking with the oliver
method but
he has like 4 000 subscribers and
basically
his bills are paid by one brand or like
one and a half brands because it's like
two units at the school
two aspects of it or something so what
i'm arguing
is that start a niche channel really
narrow your niche like margus is doing
by talking not just about virtual
meetings but hybrid virtual meetings
marcus became the number one expert on
hybrid virtual meetings in the world
how did he do that because nobody else
even claims to be
that no one jumped on it and it's only
really been a thing for a couple weeks
so he went straight to a niche as zig
ziglar says
turn away from being a wandering
generality and become a meaningful
specific
so now you talk to a particular software
company a software company and this is
where i need you to lean in coffee with
cannell
a startup a software company a company
that has a multi-million dollar budget a
year
a startup that has 10 million dollars in
funding and has to spend some of that in
marketing
and you connect with a startup company
and you say look
we can do an annual partnership
fifty thousand dollars and twice a month
i'll make a video
plus i'll be a spokesperson in those
videos for you
um and you could use those clips on your
website or on facebook content or social
media content
i will kind of be like uh the
the you know the talk show host of the
brand
however it's also connected into the
influence i do have in a particular
niche
but during that time you're essentially
also having that brand fund your growth
because if you're at 10 000 subscribers
5 000 subscribers
you're probably you probably think it's
crazy to think about getting 50 000
spread out over a year but that is the
oliver method
is going to be a lot more people are
already doing it
it's going to be super uh you'll see a
lot more of it and we're here to help
you with that as well
i basically laid it out but obviously
the nuances you got to pitch yourself
you got to build the relationships
biz dev on linkedin figure out who the
decision makers are
figure out what deliverables are and
what not is there other video production
or editing or whatever you're going to
do
but if you want to do this full time the
dream work from home
maybe have a contract for consistent
checks every single month from a brand
you're you're out here trying to get
monetized
and make 55 dollars in adsense a month
when a brand will pay you 50 000
if you do the right biz dev the right
positioning and and and develop the
right expertise
with under 5000 subscribers why are you
working for pennies and peanuts from
youtube monetization
when you can do the oliver method and
you can lock it in for a full-time
salary
from a sugar daddy brand and the sugar
daddy brand is just
brand that will pay you to basically
sponsor
a batch of content three months six
months a year of content on your channel
my friends are you getting value today
out of this
stream smash the like button we got some
water in the house
we got some bulletproof coffee in the
house we got starbucks coffee
it's coffee with candle man who is
oliver people are asking
we gotta have oliver back on the show to
talk about the method i love kombucha
any kombucha fans here you guys hate it
we got pine caleb's having some
pineapple peach kombucha
kombucha'sthebomb.com uh
did you just say brandywine coffee i did
do you know it
um my friend alex i follow him
uh on uh on instagram
and i was looking at he's in canada but
i was looking at who's here in the u.s
where i could get some bomb coffee
and i jumped on their black friday
special and ordered a couple bags and
had them shipped
uh to my house oh it's so good that's
what i'm on right now
a little bit of um
oh there's like some mango kind of this
is black coffee too like
that's that's something like grape jam
kind of
so delicious we got monsters in the
house intelligentsia
good choice intelligentsia is some
really really good coffee courtney shane
um let me explain how coffee with kennel
works because we do have to land the
plane here
pretty quick but uh coffee with candle
happens every other week we also have
the think marketing live show with
heather taurus
it'll go live here on think marketing
we'll do our best to promote it and let
you know when it's happening
we'll drop a link in the live chat so
you can click through
and then be on the uh in the back end
the room is full right now
and so the goal is to get here as soon
as that link shows up in the live chat
click through
ideally be on wi-fi in a setup or you
know
good audio and have all that dial dialed
and then we'll roll
right through it do i have a script
right now or am i freestyling free
styling right now
i don't know what this is completely
unscripted
at this point um
yeah man so much good coffee in the
house thanks for being here thanks for
being here okay let's do one more
uh and we're going to uh keep it going
we're gonna bring chris here coffee with
kennel chris what is up hey
where are you from what's your channel
about how can i help hey man
uh thanks for bringing me on sean uh my
name is chris pyron i am in tulsa
oklahoma right dev smack in the middle
of the u.s
and uh my channel actually just launched
last week i just posted my first video
up there
um my niche is really geared towards
live production technology and i'm
narrowing that down even more
specifically to like churches and house
of worship uh right now
kind of like we were just talking about
with the last guy
it's something that a lot of churches
didn't have to deal with before was
figuring out how to stream
and how to do this thing online right so
i started off uh my first video was
about how to build a
mix a live mix for your broadcast stream
you know
um and then kind of digging into that so
that's it right there yep that's the one
awesome well how can i help what's your
question today so
one of my questions was as i've been
looking at uh content
uh scheduling and some of my video ideas
and things like that
i would love to do like more like
product reviews top 10
sort of videos um we were talking about
the sugar daddy before dialing it way
back from that
what are some biz dev tactics that you
would have or some strategies that you
would
look to to address some brands
to highlight product and and do
not necessarily brand deals but but
procure product for
review and things like that great
question
um so i think first of all
uh one of the most important things i
think is
that i want everyone to hear you gotta
know who are you trying to reach
how are you going to help them and you
want to consider your tam it's the total
addressable market
right now there's churches all over the
world i just looked this up
apparently there is 47 200 churches
based on that's this is 2017
um in the us but it's
important to think about like how many
people out there are there
to help so in from chris's perspective
you might also go
well tech is so crowded no chris is
doing something amazing because he's
using his expertise
in particular related to churches
church live streaming mixing broadcast
like i can't teach you how to do this
you know what i mean you might think and
maybe you didn't think oh like this is
the same as think media are you kidding
me
i don't know how to do a broadcast mix i
don't know this sound board i don't even
know what's happening on this screen
so it's like different niches within the
niches so that's a good thing
number two is now getting into your
question chris
is kind of just thinking about
angles of biz dev biz dev could be
serving the churches directly you know
biz dev could be
uh working with brands that want to
reach churches
you know influencers kind of a funny
term but that's the goal of being an
influencer
and not thinking about it cheesy like oh
i'm selfieing myself eating a doughnut
in la
with the per like the little converse in
the shoes and i'm an influencer but it's
like
like i who do you influence john maxwell
leadership is influence
so if you influence people who are
doing church live streams then brands
want to work with you because you
influence decision makers at churches
um and those are some of the angles
strategically to think about
your world since you probably know my
background and i've got so many friends
that are in all kinds of different
aspects of this it is just massive i
mean i'll just
stream of consciousness unload um
you just kind of got to pick what you
want to do a
looping here the other thing chris is
doing smart
is this market these 47 200 churches
just in the u.s he's absolutely right
all of them are like shoot how do you
live stream and even if they were live
streaming
how do you like actually like pastor
connect relate with people online now
we're forced to be online
how do we keep this thing going how do
we do tech how do we make it more
dynamic
what's the technical side what's the
programmatic side
what is the emotional side what are the
ancillary tools around its side there's
like a zillion
sides so a couple things that i want you
to be thinking is you're making your
game plan in 2021
coffee with cannell and think media
is like who is it you serve what problem
do you solve for them
and are there any new problems that you
should pivot towards right now
because this is a major problem it's a
hot problem so it's perfect timing for
chris
to be thinking about serving this entire
group
of whether it's vendors brands content
tool makers as well as churches pastors
and everybody else
so chris at the end of the day i mean um
if it was let me ask you this what is
like your goal
do you need to do you want to hit a
financial target do you want to work
from home
um with this are you a part of your
local church are you trying to
is this supposed to be a side business
what's the end goal
of if the next 12 months helped you
reach
an influence an income and an impact
goal what would it look like 12 months
from now
sure so so the ultimate goal is for this
to be a full-time
endeavor for me um i i spent 10 years as
a church tech director
i've gone through my 12-step program and
recovering now
uh it was a it was a whirlwind of 10
years
but it was great i learned a lot during
that time uh my
my goal now is to eventually turn this
into a full-time
uh income to be able to help educate the
church on
all things tech related uh specifically
you know right now focusing on what i
what i am focusing on so starting with
you know things like you know
i've got an akg mic in front of me you
have a sure mic in front of you you know
reaching out to brands like that saying
hey i'm doing a
wireless mic you know roundup video
could i get a an xyz you know model you
know wireless mic to
add into the mix here you know is is
there a
what's what's the value add or what's
the strategy that you could go to those
manufacturers with and say hey how
how could i you know procure a piece of
gear without having to go out and spend
you know my own money or my company
money to you know try and buy a bunch of
gear that
i may not have use for after a roundup
yeah 100
okay cool so first
steps goal is full time work from home
or work with freedom
to be able to do this you've got the
chops you've got the experience that's
also a good first step
is is having a lot of expertise and
wisdom to share so now you're kind of
moving into that
teacher role um your first step
is to build influence influence comes
first income comes second
we're you're not jumping the gun but i
mean you barely have a portfolio so i
would be more
focusing on growing my subscriber base
thinking about
things you do have access to thinking
about honestly your next 30 to 50 videos
and i'd be doing at least two a week
um better quality building up that
momentum
hustling on social activating my network
hey friends
um i'd be i would actually do a lot of
what i call
hand-to-hand social media combat
which would be ask a pastor
what is your biggest question tie him
into it maybe get him on video asking it
then boom you're like hey today the
question comes from pastor randy and
this is his question
on his phone hey chris this is what i
want to know boom you answer the video
i would just and maybe randy's your
friend
and you just start making videos and
answers to specific questions
um with you take people let them know
what you're doing you start building it
up
the path to even free gear i'll hit that
but i definitely i want you to get to a
thousand subscribers before you even
really worry too much about that
i want you to really get the youtube
channel growing
um and if your goal is full time on
youtube
i want you to commit potentially to 12
months
of kind of having a whatever it takes um
willingness which i'm sure you do to
potentially i believe you can make a
full-time income in this first year you
might already have some things happening
but it might mean towards the end of the
year
you work with a software company that
pro presenter you know wants to work
with you
but at the beginning of the year you
actually do some consulting that next
month you actually do a build out
and a church help you actually build and
set up and then the month after that you
do some
like that you kind of do a year of a
switch army knife
in my opinion that's what it would take
to actually collect maybe what you need
for your financial target to
take uh take care of your family in
terms of the free gear
as soon as you've got some momentum with
a focused audience and maybe this is
this is one of the best ways
to illustrate this i want you to kind of
have like what heather torres has
and by following obviously our system
you know video ranking academy and
whatnot
she hasn't uploaded that many videos but
i want to see this many videos on your
channel
she's not uploading videos now because
she's the host of the fake marketing
podcast and everything else but yet her
channel still got 5 000 views a month
so even when you're at that number even
when you're like listen
5 000 moms a month listen
5 000 church streaming pastor
media director marketing social media
people at church watch my channel per
month
now you're already in a different place
of influence comes first
free gear comes second influence comes
first income comes second
these are strategic videos all rounds
all kinds of topics good titles good
thumb
thumbnails and they're leading to she
hasn't uploaded in like months
and she's working on because she's
pretty busy at think media
but like shifting back into this 2021
because imagine trying to run
four youtube channels by the time you
add this one right and
all that to say is
she has gotten free curriculum
homeschool curriculum companies want to
talk to her because she's got the
homeschool house in a niche
and even today without uploading like
foot in the door
real easy oh hey you make an app for
uh fire tablets to help homeschool and
this but
like would you give me the app free are
you kidding it's
she doesn't need a ton of influence to
potentially get that but you got to have
that influence but does that make sense
the year of really hustling really
getting videos posted
maybe a brand says yes but here's the
caution
i think people spend too much time too
early
emailing brands and worrying too much
about that if they're at your stage
like i would put blinders on
all the biz dev stuff matters but i
would almost
kind of be thinking about it but i'd
almost block it out of my head and take
at least three months
of just working my face off to put out
the best videos possible
hitting up my network not in a spammy
way like
yo will worship leader bro what are you
struggling with can i make
like do some coaching with them for free
and then it's like you get some ideas
and insights of what his pain points are
and that turns into some video content
hey can i record this zoom meeting and
upload it like you could upload all
kinds of stuff you could have convert
like you could have five
videos a week depending on how much time
you know what i mean and just grinding
on
getting to know your market
understanding their pains and ambitions
even though you know you don't
necessarily know how they're wording it
or what they're saying
and when it's personalized and they see
you and when you introduce yourself
hey chris here my passion is helping you
solve x and x problem and they're
listening to will the worship leader
talk to you on zoom that's uploaded on
your channel
email me if you want to work together
now a church emails you and you're like
yeah we could do a thing and i'll
you know i'll help you order the gear on
b h photo and they have financing on b
h so like i'll walk you through that
process hotel what you and then you know
i'll talk you through it on zoom or you
can fly me in and i'll set it up for you
and this is my package and like that you
might not have to always do that
especially once you hit a tipping point
but that's part of the climb in my
opinion
when you're kind of pioneering the work
from home
solo pandora influencer type of thing um
and that intimacy with the end user
pastors worship leaders directors is
insane
you could use that content it'll give
you insights
that would be my behavior for probably
about a year but at least three months
of like crazy and then at that point i
might hit sure up
and then when you ask sure
it's a lot easier to get lender units
like eventually you could probably
pioneer a deal with b h relatively easy
if you've ever seen everyday dad dude is
like a machine
on this game like every single camera
and thing that comes out
it's all lender units hey thanks b h for
like sending this over
and the power of b h photo is they have
everything
and so they just send the lender units
as opposed to
directly with sure sure might look
especially at 20 subscribers but even if
they're like even a 2000 they may be
like eh
or like no one's even replying because
that's not a huge division that's built
out for them
whereas you get one relationship with
maybe like a church media vendor
back to the sugar daddy method but a
little early maybe for
getting paid the free gear could be very
practical
just kind of a cycle of stuff coming to
you and ship back
that would be what i work to and i think
the fastest path to get there
is at least three months of sprinting
and putting out the greatest content you
possibly can
cool awesome follow-up questions or
anything
no i think that's great that that's
going to help me pivot a bunch of the
content ideas
that i had and not focus on the gear
pieces so much and focus more on
on the way to use the tools i think will
probably be the best the best thing to
go here moving forward for q1 of the of
next year
so i appreciate it thank you very much
thank you chris thanks for coming on
all right take care cheers
hit like if you're getting value out of
coffee with kennel today do you like the
show
are you having a good december what are
your plans are you traveling
are you locked down is there
stay-at-home orders where you live
are you on a pause what's happening in
your world
uh appreciate you
uh monica b and h photo
b ampersand
url's bh photo but uh b
and h a new york company great company
and so
everyday dad for example you know
you can't buy every camera but i
wouldn't think
but you'll hear him say uh i mean he
does
it's crazy the amounts of tech he covers
so a lot of times he definitely buys the
best stuff that he wants
but to do this kind of volume he's got
like a
shipping and receiving workflow going to
cover all this different tech influence
comes first though
you know income comes second and so
respect
if you go to like oldest you know
you start out on a little action camera
you start out
it's cool to watch people's progressions
you know three years ago and that's
you know to put this in perspective even
for you for chris for all of us
are you can you commit to grinding over
the next three years
like like would you be willing
to be at 256 000 subscribers
would you be willing to be getting 4.2
million views a month
um 30 new 30 000 new subscribers a month
with 20 videos published a month and be
able to do this full-time from home
i i would bet our cpms are
are the same um if not very close
on think media because we do such
similar content and so
would you be willing to work freaking
hard today as dave ramsey says live
today like no one else so later in life
you can live like no one else
so cpm at 20 rpm at 10 so that's how
much money i'm going to make
off of off of whatever 3 million views
or something right
3.3 led to about 30 thousand
so it's about 10 000 makes sense per rpm
so you know that's about 40 000
a month and i'm not trying to like hype
this up
i'm trying to say that i love seeing
that when we go to oldest were three
years ago
and he works his freaking face off
posting videos putting out putting out
good quality in his videos starting
starting with what you have this video
doesn't look as good
as his current stuff three years ago
start with where you are and get one
percent better with every upload
right and so i want to encourage you
youtube is a marathon and not a sprint
there's no guarantees but there is
systems there is strategies
there is if you come up with the right
video with the right title and the right
thumbnail and post it at the right time
with the right content it could be game
over
and you could be one video away from
triggering the algorithm triggering your
channel
and i think three years is an
interesting amount of time
to think about reaching a certain
tipping point and my friend it might
take six would you be willing to make 42
000
a month if it took you six years to get
there come on
you know what i mean like just put would
you be willing to make
25 of that and to make like 10 grand a
month and i'm talking just adsense we're
not even talking about his affiliates
right if we look at these numbers
because of the
how you know his niche and cpm and
everything else
i want to share that not to hype you up
but to give you
a clear vision of what's possible
but to fuel the hustle and the tenacity
and the commitment and the resilience
and the willingness to do whatever it
takes
and to live and work today like nobody
else
so that later in life you can live and
work like nobody else
um it's worth it friends i think you
would agree that it's worth it i'm
getting a lot of yes
you know i could i could live off you
know 42
000 a month uh evan says three years
makes sense one more to go
and it's ex-franken-natural
is that a real phrase it really is like
think media even though there's been
different i mean you look at the
the bump uh like lately things have been
insane for us
but never compare your beginning to
somebody else's middle
like we're years into this we should be
going like this
and like my friend pat flynn says uh
he says um he did this real where he
said
we think success looks like this when
you're starting your side hustle but it
actually looks like this
down back up down discouraged
start kind of hyped horrible week
horrible month
oh a little bright spot back down again
and there's a while of this
but then eventually you start lifting up
and when you commit to something over
like
one two three four five six seven eight
and if you think about just a you know
hopefully encourage
commitment to the journey commitment to
the hustle commitment to the work
if you haven't seen my think analytics
before let's look at lifetime
you know let's go to lifetime this is
just one channel i have multiple failed
youtube channels
okay and so here's 2010
right here that's pretty flat
well i also wasn't super consistent nor
did i have clarity
you might be there well what if you
can't upload a video a week upload as
many as you can
upload when you can get better so here's
five years
that was my first five years kind of
flatlined even though at times
eventually i was getting
you know even thousand views a day
that's that's a thousand that's two
thousand views a day still flat line
compared to like what's happening now
and then 2015 is when i actually went
all in
so there's something about i started to
like i i
fired all my freelance clients i got
fired from all of my freelance clients
so i was like i got no bus all i'm doing
is youtube and then i started to grind
and i had been doing all the stuff i
knew how to do for clients
so now i had no bosses and so it was
just me i worked all on my own content
and started to build and things started
getting crazy right
but this is still nothing compared to
what's happening here so you start
seeing the seasons of the journey
this is a 10-year snapshot but let me
take it a layer deeper
i got started in video seven years
before this
started i started in 2003 in video my
youth pastor handed me a video camera
and said start making videos
so the first youtube channel i started
was in 2007.
that channel failed my church's channel
i have a clear vision media channel that
didn't go anywhere
did a project called think international
was good learned a lot
was i would even say successful because
really sometimes you win
sometimes you learn not sometimes you
win sometimes you lose
it's all learning it's education so i
had these other youtube channels i was
experimenting on i started doing stuff
on my personal channel i was all over
just like talking to jay peasy easier
earlier i was all random i didn't have
clarity you might not know what your
niche is don't quit
don't stop keep going keep posting keep
learning
so seven years to get the knowledge in
the skill like chris
10 years in his career i'm learning how
to edit i'm learning cameras i'm
learning photoshop
i was working on my craft for seven
years before
i started my own youtube channel i came
into the game knowing how to edit
knowing how to do photoshop and i've
gotten better since then but i came in
to the game knowing how to do that stuff
self-taught
and then this thing happens for 10 years
and freaking now just to put in
perspective
and and i would argue this is
extraordinary success
but now every two days we get a quarter
million views
like 237 000 views every 48 hours
that's naturally bigger than people's
years bigger than the life of the whole
youtube channel happens every two days
on think media
my friend this is the compound effect
and and and i i hopefully i don't want
to be a hype guy
and just like some pie in the sky what
if you got
10 of that a quarter million that'd be
25 000 views every two days
what if you got one percent of that
that'd be 2500 views every two days
that would be remarkable one of my
favorite books darren hardy the compound
effect
is it really is small tweaks today
lead to giant peaks tomorrow
and i've been working on these small
tweaks for 17 years
and so the amount of momentum and
compact compound effect that i'm
experiencing is crazy
add other people to the mix nolan
heather melissa which is all part of
growing as a leader in team and
communication
it's even crazier add other seasons
add continuing to learn what am i trying
to communicate to you
keep going two
keep learning three
when you get discouraged take a nap
tired eyes rarely see a bright future
and get up to fight another day
there's going to be highs there's going
to be lows
my friend roberto blake you know a lot
of us i don't know who said it first
youtube is a marathon and not a sprint
but he said
youtube is a marathon and not a sprint
and the extra mile
and very few will run the extra mile i
slaughtered his quote something about
you're not going to see many people who
who wants to put in
and i'm not saying it's going to take
you 17 years here's why because you have
think media
and you have think marketing our goal
with this channel this show our podcast
video ranking academy which is our
advanced course the youtube starter kit
like all that stuff
to the degree that you invest in
yourself is just to shorten your
learning curve
not make it disappear i believe we can
cut 75
off of your learning curve 75
if you look at my 10-year journey on
youtube if i cut yours down by 75
that's gonna be two and a half years of
time in
that's this is not like some
get-rich-quick promise oh sean he's
promising like this magical cash machine
youtube algorithm hack yeah right two
and a half
nobody wants to do anything for two and
a half years you know what i mean what
if someone was like listen
you can have just a beach body chiseled
abs
guns you're gonna feel great you're
gonna look great
what is what do we want especially in
western culture
well how long is it gonna take is there
a pill i can take could i do that by
next weekend i got a christmas party and
my in-laws are going to be in there and
they're super judgmental and so i'm
thinking that i need to get something
happening quick
because they always criticize listen and
i'm like yeah
you can get this beachbody it's only
going to take you
two and a half years of eating right and
working out every day
you know what i mean you go okay just
kidding um
uh never mind there's no wait there's
not just some magic pill
wait a minute there's not just some
instant here's the key
you got to have smart workouts you got
to have smart nutrition
you got to have a smart plan you got to
have a smart strategy
like that's going to help you go faster
and my god if you really hustled with
the right plan and the right strategy
and the right coach and the right mentor
then you could probably get crazy in
three months and have a beachbody in six
months
that it would take somebody else because
you shorten your learning curve but i
want to encourage you it's still going
to take time
it's still going to take patience it's
still going to take hustle
it's still going to take you're going to
be discouraged you're going to get a
negative comment on the journey
there's going to be quitting points you
got to crash through quitting points
you got to keep learning got to keep
leveling up you got to give yourself
grace
you got to be patient with yourself like
heather torres says it's your race it's
your pace
don't get discouraged when you go who
the heck is that person they just came
out they got there in three months
doesn't matter if they got there in
three months your pace might be three
years
your pace might be like mine 17 years
but are you willing to have joy on the
journey
to embrace struggle and to just say i'm
committed to the process man
and can we have fun on the process come
on this thing can get so serious i can
get so serious my team thinks i get
really serious
like take a deep breath come on we're
making freaking youtube videos from home
i get it can be high stress i get it can
have pressure
i get you're comparing yourself to
everybody else i get that you're talking
negative to yourself
i get that your poop your pants scared
and that your armpits are sweaty
for getting on camera but you just gotta
get up and do it anyways
and take a deep breath and be like
listen to this world we're in
you didn't create the internet you
didn't create youtube you didn't create
smartphones and you didn't create
digital cameras nor did you create live
streaming equipment
these are a blessing the fact we even
have
access that coffee with cannel we can
hang out
why i sit in my house while my wife is
downstairs breastfeeding my son
sean bradley kennel and after this
stream i can roll downstairs
sit by our christmas tree finish my
coffee after talking to you
around the world on the freaking
internet can you
believe what time we're living in
gratitude deep breath
a lot of hard work but let's have joy on
the journey let's have fun in the
process
um i hope you get value out of today's
uh coffee with kannel
i'm ready to commit type all in in the
chat if you are uh
here today still and if you're enjoying
today uh sabrina i'm all in
joy on the journey i appreciate y'all
grateful for you today
uh thank you everybody who's been
hanging out coffee with kennel
got to a lot of good sessions today a
lot of good questions as i mentioned
i got to go check on the fam and get
ready for a think media leadership event
that we are doing
jump on when heather does think
marketing live once a week jump on when
i do coffee with kennel once a week
of course we're going to do some holiday
hours and some holiday schedules
so if i don't get to see you again i'll
see you next year
i mean obviously i'm gonna be posting i
may see you next year uh
i hope your holidays are going awesome
merry christmas to you from
myself and the think media team uh from
uh
las vegas and we will we have a couple
more things coming out but i'm not sure
what our schedule is
heather's here next week on the think
marketing live show check out the think
marketing podcast
every tuesday i think i may have a live
or two over on our other channel think
media
i appreciate you sending love and
respect and i can't wait
for next time and maxwell george um i
hope we can
have you on the show in the future so
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today
uh as well and uh in the meantime keep
crushing it keep smashing it and i'll
see you
on the next coffee with kennel peace